he's my son hop my son Oh Wynonna when
it comes to 80s icons yours is the name
on the tip of everyone's tongue it's
hard to believe that the duffer brothers
initially wanted to cast naomi watts or
Marisa Tomei asked Joyce instead of you
for just so happy you land at the part
but getting into character wasn't always
easy since you have no children of your
own luckily your own mother was there to
fill you in on what it takes to be a mom
[Music]
it's no secret that the cast of stranger
things is breaking records and taking
names
it doesn't matter how old or young the
actors are because chances are their net
worth speaks for itself you won't
believe which stranger things star has
the biggest net worth of all and
surprise surprise
it isn't Wynonna writer magnet I stop do
you understand Sadie sing 17-year old
actress Sadie's sink is well known for
playing the role of Max Mayfield and
stranger things
Sadie joined the cast in 2017 and it's
currently filming the upcoming film dear
Zoe
Sadie's net worth is estimated at two
hundred thousand dollars and it's not
done growing just yet Charlie Heaton
Tarly Heaton plays Jonathan Byers Will's
worried older brother the 25 year old
actors net worth doesn't top the charts
but it's only a matter of time before
does Charlie's net worth is currently at
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
Shannon purser 22 year old Shannon
purser stole our hearts as Barbara
Holland in season one of stranger things
and she's gone on to star in a handful
of popular movies and TV shows like
rivers Elle and Sierra Burgess is a
loser as of 2018
Shannon's net worth was estimated at
$400,000 prior Ferguson's prior Ferguson
may only be 13 years old but she sold us
on confidence and intelligence when she
starred as Erica Sinclair in seasons two
and three of stranger things
hi I began acting when she was 5 years
old and just like one of her co-stars
prior started acting in theatre
productions she currently has a net
worth of $500,000 daiquiri Montgomery
daiquiri Montgomery is a 22 year old
Australian actor who already has a net
worth of 1 million dollars daiquiri rose
to fame when he starred as the red
ranger Jason in the 2017 film Power
Rangers
that same year daiquiri made his Netflix
debut as Billy Hargrove in seasons two
and three of stranger things
rest in peace Billy Natalie Dyer at 22
years old now lead iers net worth is
already estimated at 2 million dollars
Natalie plays the role of Nancy wheeler
who has proven herself to be quite the
detective Natalie started acting when
she was cast in Hannah Montana the movie
at just 12 years old
Joe Curie Joe Curie is the man behind
Steve the hare Harrington oh yeah Joe
used to be one of the guitarists in the
Vans post animal but as of 2019 he
strictly focusing on his acting career
at 27 years old Joe has a net worth of
2.7 million dollars Noah snap in 2015
Noah Schnapp got his big break when he
voiced Charlie Brown in the peanuts
movie and just one year later Noah
snagged the lead role of will tires and
stranger things
Noah isn't your average teenager after
all he does have a net worth of three
million dollars one of Noah's co-stars
has a net worth six times bigger than
his own but will reveal who that is at
the end of this video
Caleb McLaughlin Caleb McLaughlin is the
town's
actor who portrays Lucas and Claire and
all three seasons of stranger things oh
my god hopeless he celebrated his 18th
birthday in October of 2019 like most of
his young co-stars caleb has a net worth
of three million dollars fin Wofford 16
year old actor Finn Wofford is just
getting started
and he already has more acting credits
than someone twice as aid Finn plays
Mike wheeler and stranger things but has
also starred in productions like it
family and the turning Finn has a net
worth of three million dollars Lilly
Bobby Brown Millie Bobby Brown is an
oscar-winning actress in the making she
rose to fame by playing the mysterious
and powerful 11 in stranger things they
say we're species what emotion and she's
currently cast in upcoming films like
Godzilla versus Kong and Enola Holmes at
15 years old Milly has a net worth of
three million dollars Gatton matarazzo
Dustin Henderson is played by Gatton
matarazzo who is the first and only
choice for his role unlike his on-screen
besties Gatton has a net worth of four
million dollars Gabby who turned 17 in
September of 2019 has been a Broadway
star since he was only eight years old
Cara Bonin Cara bro know is the seasoned
actress who plays Karen wheeler and all
three seasons of stranger things car is
well known for starring in TV series
like The Sopranos and Mad Men cars net
worth is estimated at four million
dollars david harbor david harbor has a
net worth of four million dollars the 44
year old celeb started acting in 2002
and quickly shot to stardom david is
best known for playing Elevens father
figure Jim hopper and stranger things
Wynonna writer Wynonna rider is an
actress who needs no introduction she
has a net worth of 18 million dollars
which is six times greater than her
on-screen son Noah snaps net worth but
believe it or not
why known as net worth isn't the biggest
of the bunch nope that title goes to
Joyce Myers ex-boyfriend Bob newbie Sean
Astin Sean Astin who plays Bob in season
two of stranger things takes the cake
with a net worth of 20 million dollars
the Lord of the Rings star is truly one
of the kinds tell us who your favorite
stranger things character is in the
comments thanks for watching subscribe
to the things and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up we'll catch
you next time
[Music]